the first wave of digital is going by
where people have essentially been
focused on digitizing what they already
had so you have newspapers online and
radio online and TV online and a lot of
people first thought well that's it and
now they realize that's just the first
part and now it means starting to do
things online that you otherwise would
not be able to do offline and that's
what a lot of companies are discovering
now the ones that are the incumbents in
the offline world they're just starting
to discover that that's just the first
part of being online is being digital
and now we're getting into the piece
where it's about being connected being
connected in a way that you otherwise
wouldn't be able to be connected being
able to can connect to individual people
so in media connecting with the people
formerly known as the audience but you
can take that into education and you can
connect with the people formerly known
as students or you can connect with the
people formerly known as patients
because the technology exists now to be
able to engage with individuals and also
get the massive amounts of data that
come from that so that's a significant
shift that's occurring right now some of
the immersive video 360 video experience
that we've done have been of Syrian
refugee camps so that you get more of a
visceral feeling for what that feels
like what it looks like by being able
and by the way it's not just the video
the sound being able to get 360 sounds
so that when you turn your head you're
you hear things in a different way so
that experience has to come together and
that is much richer has much
more information packed in it which
gives you more context for the story
right now let's not forget that whether
it's straight linear video or VR
oftentimes you're still trying to tell a
story
it isn't just visiting the Grand Canyon
and being in your living room but you're
in the Grand Canyon and you're looking
around that's that's not a particular
story but when you're doing journalism
about hey what does life in a refugee
camp look like there's a narrative there
there's a story and so being able to
immerse yourself adds more texture more
richness to that experience but still
you have to do it in such a way that it
doesn't detract from being able to pick
up the story and that's where I think
this is tricky because I think that the
technology is ahead of the storytelling
around it because I think storytellers
still feel more comfortable in tight
linear narrative right they've already
written a script and they're just out
there to shoot things according to the
script right versus being able to open
that up and then how do you do that
while maintaining the storylines that
you want to provide people are still
figuring that out the example I give to
folks is like when grand theft auto came
out you know as a video game and it
wasn't just a set of missions that you
progress through but they created a
world and you can roam freely throughout
the world and that world was then
loosely coupled to these missions so
sometimes you were just roaming around
experiencing what that was about and
then you'd go back into mission
progression mode then you jump out and I
actually think that's the way
that we operate we're yeah we're not
always in transactional mode yeah we're
transacting we're progressing and then
we're experiencing everything around us
and I think that's what VR 360 video
gives us the opportunity to do